In the summer of 2020,
after the murder of George Floyd,
we saw one of the largest
series of protests for racial justice
in American history.
Millions of people, mostly young,
a plurality white,
poured into the streets
to assert that Black Lives Matter,
and to demand police accountability
and racial justice.
Some optimistically thought
that this was the beginning
of a racial reckoning.
We painted murals on the streets.
We took down statues.
Members of Congress,
draped in kente cloth,
took a knee in the capital's
Emancipation Hall.
But just three years later,
we are engulfed in a full backlash.
We have seen a raft of bills,
in statehouses across the country,
to restrict voting and protests,
as well as bills meant to restrict
how race, gender and history
can be discussed in schools.
Wokeness,
a mantra during
the Black Lives Matter movement,
was converted into a pejorative,
and used against the movement.
This is, unfortunately,
a repeat of the tired and exhausting dance
that America does:
when Black people make progress --
some white people feel threatened
and respond with force.
This seems to happen in a major way
every 50 years or so.
The advances of Reconstruction
were followed by Jim Crow.
The advances of the Great Migration,
which was the relocation
of millions of African Americans,
primarily from the rural South
to cities in the North and West,
was met with the violence of Red Summer.
The advances of the Civil Rights Movement
were followed by mass incarceration.
I, for one, am sick of this dance.
Audience: Yes.
(Applause)
I am sick of taking two steps forward
and one step back.
Sick of the periods
when progressives grow weary
and conservatives grow vicious.
Sick of being told
that now is not the moment
for the most ambitious efforts
towards actual justice.
I want to sidestep all of that.
I want a plan for equality now,
one that does not require
marching and pleading,
one in which Black people
can access true American equality
by their own actions.
One that cannot be so easily
regressed or reneged upon.
And I just so happen to have such a plan.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Energizing reverse migration
by encouraging even more Black people
to leave cities in the North and West
and return to the South.
And I want them to do so, primarily,
to concentrate and increase
their political power,
to have greater influence over
and access to state power.
(Applause)
States control the lion's share
of many of the issues
crucial to Black people:
criminal justice, judicial processes,
election administration, education --
that's just to name a few.
And this plan wouldn't create
a new condition,
but rather restore a historical condition.
At the end of the Civil War,
three southern states
were majority Black --
South Carolina, Mississippi and Louisiana.
Three others, Alabama,
Florida and Georgia,
were within eight percentage points
of being majority Black.
Indeed, 90 percent of all Black people
at the time in this country
lived in the American South.
Enslavers had flooded the region
with captive Black people,
producing, for themselves
and the country, staggering wealth.
They never imagined that, one day,
those Black people would be free,
let alone that the 14th and 15th
Amendments would make them citizens,
and, at least the Black men, voters.
This made Mississippi a center of power
during Reconstruction,
because in places like Mississippi,
at least for a time,
Black men were the majority
of registered voters.
The state sent scores of Black
representatives to the statehouse,
and it gave America
its first two Black senators.
But, cue the music,
because the backlash dance
was about to begin.
Fearing what they called
“Black domination,”
white terrorists in the South
began a coordinated campaign of violence
and voter suppression.
They clawed back enough power
to call constitutional conventions,
during which they wrote white supremacy
into the DNA of those states.
That codified oppression
became known as "Jim Crow."
So you have chronic racial terror,
a suffocating legal structure,
and a lagging economy in the South.
That came at the same time
that northern factories
were recruiting workers.
This push and pull helped
to launch the Great Migration.
In the wake of that migration,
only slightly more than half
of all Black people in America
remained in the South.
In short,
one of the reasons that Black people
lost their majorities
in southern states
was because of terrorism.
And as America and the world
have learned all too well,
you can never let terrorists win.
And that is one of the reasons --
(Applause)
That is one of the reasons
that I believe that Black people
should return to the South.
If Black people today
had their pre-Great Migration percentages
in southern states,
they could again vote to ensure
more equitable state-level policies,
and they could put more pressure
on the federal government,
because they could control
or form the controlling interest
for more Electoral College votes
than California and New York
state combined.
And that's important here in America,
because each state has as many electors
as they have Members of Congress.
And when you go to vote for president,
you're actually voting
for that candidate's slate of electors.
It is those electors
who determine the presidency.
Black people could also be decisive
in electing several governors
and senators.
Now, in an ideal world,
we wouldn't need to concentrate
Black voting power
to achieve equality.
Any composition of voters
should provide equality for all people.
But we don't live in that ideal world.
In the world that we occupy,
anti-Black racism is still
openly manifest in policy and power,
and candidates who support
those policies continue to win
and continue to block progress.
Now, there are multiple
challenges and unknowns
that a plan like this could face,
but it has three major
things going for it.
First, there is a precedent
for it to succeed.
In the April 1972 issue of "Playboy" --
and before you say that, yes,
some people used to read it
for the articles.
(Laughter)
It featured a piece
by writer Richard Pollak,
entitled "Taking Over Vermont,"
in which Pollak proposed
that the nation's alienated
young do just that.
Pollak's article sprang
from an obscure 1971 paper
entitled "Jamestown Seventy,"
published at Yale by two law students.
In it, the authors put forth
the tantalizing idea
that they called "radical federalism,"
the migration of large numbers
of people to a single state,
for the express purpose of effecting
a peaceful political takeover of the state
through the elective process.
Indeed, many young people
were already moving to Vermont
before these things were written.
But the plan worked.
As writer Yvonne Daley has noted,
"Vermont was transformed,
electing more progressive
politicians per capita
in the intervening years than any state,
and enacting legislation
that routinely resulted
in Vermont ranking among the most
liberal states in the union."
I am proposing that, in the same way
that young white liberals
moved en masse to one
of the whitest states in the union
with a political intent,
that young Black people move
to some of the Blackest states,
with the same political intent.
The second thing that the plan
has going for it
is that the reverse migration
is already happening.
Reporters have been chronicling this
for at least a decade.
I myself am part of the reverse migration,
moving from Brooklyn to Atlanta in 2020.
In fact, Georgia is a nexus
of the reverse migration.
Still, the reverse migration
is nowhere near as robust and energetic
as its predecessor.
To match the scale of the Great Migration,
the reverse migration
needs an adrenaline boost,
and that is exactly
what I am trying to provide.
And third, the reverse migration
is already paying dividends
in the form of more state-level power.
In 2020, Georgia flipped from red to blue,
for the first time since Bill Clinton
won the state in 1992.
(Cheers and applause)
And the voters also elected
two Democratic senators,
one Black and one Jewish.
(Cheers and applause)
The coalition of voters
that made that possible
was led by Black voters,
who constituted a majority
of those voting for Biden,
according to election estimates.
The success of the Democratic
Party's gains in Georgia
can in part be attributed to a rise
in the Black population in this state.
In the early 1990s, when Bill Clinton won,
Black people were about a quarter
of the state's population.
In 2020, they were about a third
Now, in theory,
my proposal isn't partisan.
The point is freedom, not party loyalties
or party punishments.
But in 2020,
the candidates chosen by the vast
majority of Black people won,
making Georgia a model for resurgent
Black power in the South,
and for me and the plan that I advanced,
making Georgia proof of concept.
It is one thing to diagram a problem,
to render it in poetry and passion,
to build a case.
It is something of a different order
to propose a plan.
This is the difference
between talking or asking,
or pleading and demanding,
and just doing.
As Frederick Douglass once said
about escaping slavery,
"I prayed to God to emancipate me.
But it was not until I prayed with my legs
that I was emancipated."
I am asking as many Black people
in America who are able
to do like Douglass.
To pray with your legs and migrate.
Thank you very much.
(Cheers and applause)